just as your body is battling one
life-threatening disease cancer cells
may pose a risk of getting another
disease a new study from the university
of san diego examines why that happens
and the study appeared last week in
science daily in our buddy czech 8
report denise valdez talks to the author
and why the study may prompt more breast
cancer screenings or patients rather to
get screened for diabetes
dr emily wong is a professor of
pathology at uc san diego's school of
medicine i really want to do something
to understand the link between these two
diseases she and her research team just
released the results of a study it
describes a possible biological
mechanism in which breast cancer
suppresses the production of insulin
which results in diabetes that at the
same time impairs blood sugar control
promoting tumor growth so we show that
breast cancer
can also
predispose
the patients cancer patients or breast
cancer survivors
to a higher risk of developing diabetes
so she's talking about women who have no
family history or predisposition to
diabetes until after they had breast
cancer although very early in its
findings it's certainly a good habit
to check your insulin and your blood
your blood glucose as you're being
treated for breast cancer
yes especially for those patients who do
not have diabetes so they think oh i
don't have this disease i only have
cancer but that means there may be a
higher chance for the other disease for
diabetes this could lead to a better
understanding of how the two conditions
help each other and that could lead to
treatments which can restore normal
insulin production and suppress tumor
growth okay i should focus on cancer
treatment because that's more lethal but
you know controlling the blood glucose
is always always important patients with
both breast cancer and diabetes have
worse clinical outcomes and worse
survival rates so dr wong recommends
pre-screenings and closely watching your
glucose and your insulin levels for
buddy check denise valdez live local now